réaction évidemment après ces tirs russe
sur le port d'odessa gauthier rybinski
bonjour c'étaient des bombardements des
missiles qu'on reconnaît avoir lancé les
russes aujourd'hui ça a pour conséquence
l'augmentation des prix du blé déjà on a
eu on est les communiqués à ce propos il
ya quelques instants les russes qui
tente malgré tout de rassurer
partenaires africains ils évoluent et
ces derniers jours ces dernières heures
oui parce que vous souvenez de la visite
de macky sall qui est en charge de
l'union africaine c'était tout récent à
moscou et qui expliquait qu' il ne
pouvait pas se prononcer lui pour ou
contre la russie parce que il était
dépendant des céréales russes et pas
uniquement des engrais aussi russes par
ricochet on pouvait se demander
d'ailleurs ce que l'afrique avait fait
pour essayer de conquérir cette
indépendance alimentaire et que lorsque
l'afrique certains pays d'afrique
prétendait tout à fait légitimement être
sur la scène internationale au plus près
des réalités et bien dans une certaine
manière ils se tiraient une balle dans
le pied lorsqu'il devenait ultra
dépendant de moscou voire de kiev alors
sur cette affaire de d'odessa et la
manière dont lavrov parcours où se rend
en afrique à deux choses la première
chose c'est qu'effectivement le
comportement de moscou dans cette
affaire du bombardement d'odessa et de
nature quand même à jeter un doute chez
les partenaires africains sur l'avs la
confiance qu'on peut accorder en la
russie le deuxième point c'est que
seriez lavrov doit réanimer un sentiment
qui peut être étaient un pas ce que
c'est et un parce que les générations
passées mais c'est le sentiment qui
découlent du soutien que l'union
soviétique avait apporté jadis aller à
l'époque donc dans les années 60 aux
indépendances africaines et même au delà
c'est à dire que l'union soviétique
avait un contact privilégié avec tous
ces pays qui avaient rompu leurs
tutelles avec leur tutelle
coloniale et qui se développe et très
souvent avec une sorte de vulgate plus
ou moins marxiste qui convenait à moscou
donc c'est ça que va rappeler lavrov en
disant si vous avez des doutes souvenez
vous de la manière dont nous vous avons
aidé c'est comme ça il ne soyez pas
tributaire des événements les événements
peuvent changer c'est ce que dit lavrov
à l'instant où on nous accuse toujours
d'être à l'origine cette crise
alimentaire c'est vrai qu'elle n'a pas
commencé avec l'invasion de l'ukraine et
que l'invasion de l'ukraine et de
manière unilatérale de la part de moscou
est grandement active est grandement
aggravée par cette cette opération
spéciale nous on dit toujours opérations
spéciales les russes sont les termes
heureux ils ont tellement peu confiance
en leurs partenaires et ont leurs
populations qui continuent d'exprimer
ses sept pas de guerre sous ce vocable
là alors sur ce dossier en tout cas eux
craignant sur ce dossier des céréales
l'ukraine continue à croire en ses
exportations aldi elle s'attend à des
premières exportations dès cette semaine
sur le front les ukrainiens également
qui font état de plusieurs avancées
avancées notamment dans la région de
kherson en croire pierre alors sur les
céréales ukrainienne on voit bien qu on
est dans une concurrence vis-à-vis de
l'afrique à celui de la russie et de
l'ukraine qui sera le plus fiable et
quand kiev 10 nous voulons absolument
exporter nos cedral c'est non seulement
parce qu'ils en veulent le produit ça
c'est pas gagné mais qu'ils veulent
montrer leur bonne volonté face à moscou
curé d attitude un peu changeantes et
versatile sur la question du front si
vous voulez on a assisté à des retraits
ukrainiens notamment de la région de
lougansk parce que d'une part l'armement
n'était pas arrivé assez vite et que au
fond face à la puissance russe il
fallait essayer de se détacher pour
empêcher une nouvelle conquête russe qui
l'a serait beaucoup plus dommageable
c'est la conquête de tout le pourtour de
la mer noire et de ce fait là le repli
vers des régions comme grayson sont
censées faciliter un éventuel
encerclement de l'armée russe et surtout
j'en terminerai là avec une les canons
par exemple canon caesar d'arriver à
c'est au dessus des lignes russes pour
endommager et d'une certaine manière
pour plomber les tout ce qui est
logistique rue c'est-à-dire munitions
carburant etc voilà le but de la
manoeuvre et voilà pourquoi les
ukrainiens s'étaient retirés d'un
certain nombre de lignes de front pour
mieux se concentrer disons sur une ville
comme klaxons merci beaucoup à gauche